catastrophic earthquake scenarios have
played out on the silver screen for
decades terrifying viewers with quake
sucking collapse skyscrapers or topple
entire cities here's what will happen if
the big one hits the west coast on July
4th 2019 Ridgecrest California was hit
with a 6.4 magnitude earthquake and then
a seven point one just one day later the
neither of these compared to the long
awaited big one which scientists predict
will eventually rattle the golden coast
but when it hits what will that actually
look like here's what experts say could
happen in the seconds hours and days
after the big one while experts can't
know exactly when a quake will occur
they have a pretty good idea of where
California is located in a hot zone of
fault lines the most notorious of them
the San Andreas Fault you know here in
California have dangers from a number of
different kinds of earthquakes you know
the major danger is from the earthquakes
on the San Andreas Fault system
on average the San Andreas Fault
ruptures every 150 years the southern
parts of the fault have remained
inactive for over 200 years we haven't
had a big earthquake in Southern
California really since 1857 in other
words were overdue for a major shake
according to a 2008 federal report the
most likely scenario is a 7.8 magnitude
quake that would rupture a 200-mile
stretch along the southernmost part of
the fault
it's basically moving the ground several
yards over an area of 50 square miles so
the you know the power of 19 7.8
earthquake is probably a little close to
the power used in the whole state for a
year basically something that we as a
civilization have trouble creating with
shorter like a nuclear explosion if
you're near the epicenter of the
earthquake it will be nearly impossible
to stand people have this idea of
running out of bed out of their
buildings and that's that's a terrible
idea
because a lot of what we see in
earthquakes is people with broken legs
and people who run through glass and the
best thing to do like we always say is
duck cover and hold get under some piece
of furniture the main point is to
protect your head and chest during and
immediately following the shaking
buildings could collapse the number of
buildings that were constructed before
about 1980 is really significant and
most of these buildings are very
vulnerable to damage and collapse in
this time-lapse video you can see how
building components would hold up in a
high magnitude earthquake because the
San Andreas will produce the kind of
long period shaking which would be very
damaging to very tall building say in
downtown LA and Century City and Long
Beach and so forth
the older steel buildings the
connections in them have not necessarily
been designed to withstand the maximum
forces that actually can be generated
unreinforced structures are the least
stable but even buildings up to code
could crumble the building code with its
minimum requirements does not ensure
that the building will be serviceable
after an earthquake its intended to not
kill anybody there's a sense that if
it's modern code designed its earthquake
proof and everything should be great but
that's not the reality five steel
high-rises could collapse completely
while ten others will be red-tagged
or unsafe to enter and no the quake
would not cause a tsunami despite what
movies would have you believe to trigger
tsunami it takes an earthquake that
moves the ocean floor
and most of the San Andreas is on land
so there'd be a little bit of waves
generated from San Andreas earthquake
but nothing would be dangerous
the quake could kill about 1,800 people
only 50,000 or more with injuries while
people could die from falling debris and
collapse structures the highest death
toll would be from fires historically
the biggest hazard from earthquakes has
been fire in the 1906 earthquake there
are three or four thousand people who
were just caught in that wave of fire
that swept through the city the
aftermath of the big one will wreak
havoc on infrastructure and the economy
below our streets and our buildings is
this really complicated network of
infrastructure that could be damaged and
a lot of the things we take for granted
everyday won't be available anymore
right like water electricity being able
to drive where you need to drive parts
of the San Andreas Fault intersect with
39 gas and oil pipelines this could
rupture high pressure gas lines
releasing gas into the air and igniting
potentially deadly explosions so if you
have natural gas lines that rupture
that's how you can get fire and
explosions and after the fires burn out
one of the biggest concerns in a major
earthquake is access to fresh water
the major aqueduct networks that pump
water into Southern California all cross
the San Andreas Fault and could be
seriously damaged so we would be without
the lifelines that bring in imported
water to the region they cross through
tunnels cross through aqueducts near the
surface all of these would be ruptured
and so we would be losing 60% of our
water supply
many of these distribution lines for
water are near sewer lines which would
also be broken so now you have a
situation where contaminants are
potentially getting into the water
supply experts say you should keep at
least a two-week supply of water
your home as the ground shakes and
sediment shift there will be landslides
throughout Ventura and western Los
Angeles
there could be thousands of landslides
there have been earthquakes that have
produced thousands landslides definitely
can cause fatalities property damage we
have a lot of people who live up in the
hills right and so that's the location
where you would be likely to see
landslides affecting people and finally
the big one will severely impact the
economy major transportation networks
like highways and railways could be
unusable for weeks and even months some
bridges may not be passable after an
earthquake we've had bridges collapse
during past earthquakes you might start
seeing key industries leave population
loss and this could have you know
devastating long-term impacts for the
region the estimated financial cost of
the big one is a whopping 200 billion
with 33 billion in building damages and
50 billion in lost economic activity
this all sounds pretty bad
but keep in mind that this is based off
of a worst-case scenario the true impact
of a major earthquake is based on a
range of unknowable factors also smaller
earthquakes on faults directly beneath
major population centers are a serious
concern but the worst case the
earthquakes are hard to predict you know
that earthquake in Japan in 2011 their
cost almost entirely came because their
nuclear power plant melted down it's
very hard to predict what's going to
fail in a big earthquake so how can
Californians prepare for the big one we
really have a plan in place you know
where are you going to meet what are you
going to do have water ready I have a
55-gallon drum full of water there's
some chemical additive I put in it so
it's potable for five years 55 gallons
is the right amount for my I have a
family of four that'll last us for two
weeks canned food you know you have to
be ready I would say it's best just to
plan to stay sort of where you are
getting out of La it's bad enough
without an earthquake right traffic's
already terrible if roads are closed and
people are all trying to leave it's
going to really be
[Music]